You know,
Louis Ck,
a while back talked about Tiger Woods,
which I really liked it because people
were complaining about Tiger Woods in
his affairs.
Yeah.
And also about our Arnold Schwarzenegger
in his affairs.
And um,
and one of the things that Louis Ck
pointed out quite in a very comical
manner was that,
well many men aren't having the affairs
of Tiger Woods,
but that's not because they're good man.
It's because they don't have,
I think he said,
a busload of Swedish Swedish bikini
models waiting for them at the final
hole.
So the idea would be that you should
conduct yourself so that you are
attractive to many women.
Maybe that you have your pick of the,
but then you should pick one.
And that's a sacrifice.
Obviously that's a sacrifice of a sort.
It's a strange sacrifice because,
you know,
I,
I talked to someone,
a comedian recently who told me of one
of his experiences in Las Vegas.
So he went to Las Vegas with a sports
superstar and they went to a party.
And what literally happened at the party
was one woman brought forward a small
group of other women.
All very attractive and basically told
the sports legend that he could just
pick one of them and she would go home
with them.
Right?
And so that had all been arranged
beforehand and he said that he's been in
many situations where something like
that has happened and I thought,
well,
you know,
that sort of is appealing to the Hugh
hefner playboy,
14 year old fantasy that sort of gripped
our culture from the 19 sixties onward.
But imagine that you sleep casually with
100 women in,
in,
in a six month period or three month
period for that matter,
or a three week period.
I don't care.
Pick your timeframe and you say,
well,
what?
What?
You're,
you're,
you're ecstatic with yourself because
you've been validated by this
opportunity and I'm not making light of
that.
It's not nothing to be attractive to
women like that.
It's really something to be attractive
to women like that,
but it isn't obvious to me that your
choice to conduct yourself in that
manner enriches your life and the life
of other people more in any way than
picking one person and actually having a
relationship with them.
It's only true that that promiscuous
pathway,
let's say is better if you can actually
divorce sexuality from all the other
elements of life,
say well,
it's about variety and it's about
impulsive pleasure or maybe it could be
even slightly deeper than merely
impulsive pleasure.
It can be shared,
impulsive,
pleasure,
but I don't think you can do that
because sexuality isn't divorced from
family and from morality and from all
the other elements.
Your life and if you're a mature,
you know that and so you make a
decision.
You make a decision not to capitalize on
your opportunity,
not to misuse your opportunities and you
know,
a huge part of the me too phenomenon.
A huge part of this battle that's being
played out in our culture is a
consequence of the failure of men to
recognize that now it's not only the
failure of men.
Let me be absolutely clear about that
because for example,
with the example of the sports
superstar,
the women who are lining up in front of
him,
parading themselves and offering
themselves are deeply complicit in,
in this pathological game.
And so it's pretty clear
anthropologically as well that,
you know,
sexual choice tends towards a prieto
distribution,
especially for men.
So most men have very little selection
at their disposal disposal and a small
number of men have excess opportunities.
The question is what should that small
number of men do?
And you might say capitalize on it and
to hell with the consequences.
And like it's a powerful argument,
but I do believe it's wrong.
It destabilizes the society.
And so,
and I also don't think it does your soul
any good because the problem with
treating other people as casual sexual
partners,
let's say,
is that you also treat yourself that way
simultaneously.
And I don't think that that does you any
good because you're not.
Unless that's what you want to be.
If you want to be a casual partner,
it's like,
wow,
that's.
I wouldn't say that's a particularly
noble ambition.
You should be able to do better than
that.